こげちゃん肇社長です皆様メルカリってご存知でしょうか
おそらく見てる人の95%強化していると思うんですけども
簡単に言うとものを振ったり買ったりできるサービスのことでございます
今トップつ落としてはなんか3分で売れるみたいな wiki 出したらもうすぐ
売れる
僕もよく後輩にメルカリで有用カード合わせても
であのもうもちろん中困るんですけども新品もあって体がよりも安く買えるという特徴
があります
メアド最近なんですけどもまぁウチに来る人が増えこれもの木へ
散らかりもう壊滅状態なんですよ
家がもうちょっとものが御席で本当にどうしようかなということでちょっとこれを機に
遊び社長
メリーします
何愚かなでメルカリって何か物の値段を自分で高設定できるみたいなんでちょっと最初
でよくわかんないんだよ
全部線西竹ましょう常にサインもつけておきましょう
たとえずっと出品するものをあるデトロイト日たんで
まずはこちらですはいデュエルディスク
年間に昔たまに多分使ったと思うんですけど
遊戯王のにキャラクターがこれを使ってテープでにつけて
これで準備すると思うんですけど間口関係になって思います
そんなにれだった汚れは多少ありぐらいだと思います出兵します
続いてこちらルービックキューブですねでもこれで結構やりこんでた記憶があるんです
よねうんべく切るちょっと覚えようと思ったんですけどやっぱ難しい
[音楽]
ひぁっあった大家ですよねまあしぴじゃあし
床とコメントするとすると口が張って開くんでお話ができます
名前が乱れさせる出すので出品します西こちらですここですね
長い文近くね入った入ったぽく子です
でも僕の李芸先例がぬいぐるみ客さんにとっちゃ癖があって気づいたらなんか永住が
ぬいぐるみになってて
猫ぞ列樹に行くとこの後1
万寿台になってしまって出品気になってしまいましたごめんねポップ子
許してあとはこちらで13.5ユーロで買いました
ローマンの選手のおもちゃですこれで歯科大学
年生の時にイタリアに旅行したことがあってその時にこれが付いなんですけどかまだ
さんのお土産を買おうと思って
ローマで買ったんですよか皆さんように系とちょっと渡したい水がなくても少しになっ
てしまいま
家に置いてありますポイントとしては交換用で平面と盾が付いているのでカスタマイズ
して戦うことができます
おめでとうございます多分花花さんはこれを
なっても運って言いそうな気がしたので出品させていただきます
それではこちらでもう動画ね活躍者となると思いますドラです
僕の手違いで今ドラゲーに3個あるんですよ実は
普通にニコはいらないんで出品させていただきます
これを1000円です
あと美品あるんですけどもここから結構まずで普通に
戦へんってなるぐらいだと思いますお次はこちら
ドミネとねー
[音楽]
拙者ユーザーみたいです待ってパレ混ぜ高かった気がするなぁ
ならドリランド結局に凝ってるねぇいいと思うんですよね打っても1個ぐらいです
引越でしょ
を
あ
いいとですね
おっ
うん
福来ああああああ
っていう感じで犯罪ケースを高いとさばける中でございます
飾っておくだけでもめちゃくちゃカッコいいと思うんでこれはマジでを変えとけたと
思いますよ
さあ最後の出品です最後はこちらババーン
僕が長年使っていた一眼レフカメラ eos 70 d でございますこれサイレンズ
はないんですけど本体です電池も向いてるんですけども
全然本体はバリバリ元気ですなんならこの9液晶フィルムを貼ってあります
方あの空気がたくさん入っています僕初準備新しい買ったんで
70 d 使うことがなかったんですけどこれで誰かに買ってもらえるんだったら
おかげで出品してもいいなと思ったんで今回出品させていただきます
はいという感じでこちらの物を全部出品させていただきます
でひょっと世話いらないと言う方もいたコスメんですけども全部ちょっとサインを書か
させていただきます
私が書かせていただきます
あれはで終わったごめんなさいビダルさせるには書けないのでこれは式辞のサインを
つけさせていただきます
[音楽]
こりゃサインを維持するならた服出さない方がいいやつ感じですね
というわけでですねちょっとメルカリの出品用に写真を撮らせて頂きます
引越大丈夫
はいというわけでいかがでしょうかちょっと本当にね買うだけでお得みたいなのもある
んですけど僕の商品は25日から出品されますので皆さんよかったらぜひ買ってみて
ください
そしてなんとメルカリさんがですね今日と明日が5周年記念ということで10%オフの
クーポン券がもらえる日でございます
皆さんよかったら是非メルカリで僕が使っていたものを買ってください
そしてなんと僕だけではなくですね今日から6月の30日までいろんなクリエイター
さんやタレントさんがいろんな物を出品しているみたいでございます
いやでも俺が一番破格な自信はあるんですけどねというわけで詳しくは概要欄を見て
ください
じゃん
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ